schön ruhig bleiben kleines
es wird jetzt musst du noch die polizei
schnell genug auf nicht schnell genug
mutig sind wir daheim
schiffen auch nicht zahlen
der schütze
ablehnung
ab
solltest du nicht länger im krankenhaus
bleiben nein eine nacht hat gereicht
dickschädel gegnern
du musst jetzt schöner auf dich
aufpassen
ihr seid ihr jetzt zu zweit ja es wäre
beinahe die hose gegangen
wenn sind würde jetzt ja noch immer jot
jejange
ich finde das schön hast du schon wieder
darüber lachen kannst so was vergisst
man nicht so schnell
irgendwie scheine ich das unglück
anzuziehen
erst findet jetzt lukas ein psycho nach
den anderen irgendwas mache ich falsch
was zu tun
das liegt doch nicht an dir psychos und
idioten gibt es überall und du hast auch
nette leute kennen ich weiß nicht wo ich
jetzt wäre wenn er nicht gewesen wird
wir müssen jetzt nach vorne schauen es
kaum aufregende zeiten auf uns zu
vor allem auf dich
und wie geht es bei dir jetzt weiter
irgendwie wird es weitergehen
wir suchen uns wahrscheinlich einen
neuen produktionsleiter um das projekt
abzuschließen
hier bringt man jetzt sehr
verständnisvoll auch dank franziska und
alex ich möchte nicht beruflich sondern
privat